hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Bonnies simulator now
this is a fan-made five nights at
Freddy's games and I made a point not to
play a lot of these unless they actually
interested me and this one is
interesting because it seems to take the
Pili's from the perspective of the
bouncer so the first thing you need to
know is how to move you have a move
timer that is constantly going down if
it is above zero then you have to wait
for it reach zero for Bonnie to move
this is to restrict the player from
going for 21 on the night guard the
night guard is kind of dumb to move
Bonnie you have to follow up on his path
by clicking on the camera buttons if you
don't know Bonnie's path in five nights
at Freddy's and try clicking on nearby
cameras you were trying to get in the
office which is labeled on the map is
layout its guard just get as close as
you can to the office and then click on
the office area on the mat layout now
that you know how to move you need to
know how to attack if you're at the door
in the office and your move timer is at
zero and the door isn't closed then a
button will appear to attack once you
click it you will enter the office but
the night guard has his camera up you
have to wait for him to put it down to
attack if you're at the door and the
door is closed and your move timer is at
zero and you will automatically be
teleported back to the dining area
oh so this is honestly and truly an
actual simulator of how to play Bonnie
the monster from the original five
nights at Freddy's which I haven't
played in a long time oh you can buy it
from the shop oh boy I don't have any
points okay never mind then I'll get
that later
let's go bonbon let's have a fun time
mr. monster oh I'm gonna go Oh whoop
whoop and bike yeah look at me go
Oh I can't get to the non-accessible
areas that's exactly what I love to do
oh wait I wasn't supposed to be in here
okay so I gotta wait until the camera is
up so if the cameras oh he might be
looking at me oh hello oh hi oh the
office from the guards point of view how
do I yeah
oh I feel those interest oh yeah I feel
accomplished oh cool
those interesting
and it's so cool this is why I choose to
play games that are interesting instead
of games that are just what they are
that was cool
wait a minute but if he's kind of dumb
that means that does it get any harder
Oh
the music's different now I don't know
if he gets any harder though I mean if
it's always gonna be like this then it's
not gonna be particular time I'm booking
it hello oh you gonna do some unison
hurry not buddy
oh the monsters here bonbons guarantee I
don't know it's simple but it's fun okay
I'm gonna see if I can buy a spring-trap
because that's pretty simplistic and I
imagine the spring-trap probably adds a
little bit
ah but it's so fun and happy even though
I'm a horrible monster that's brutally
murdering a garden it's his unsuspecting
office and the guy playing is not very
good I gotta say is king in our five
nights at freddy's you know very good
okay so if i unlock extras yes please oh
he was fun okay
all right I got this extras in atronics
okay
okay so I just got to play a few times
get some points so I can get spring-trap
and then I'll play spring-trap a few
times I hope that's royalty-free music
probably not dum da dum dum uh-oh looks
like someone's gonna get bond
hey bond hey buddy hey buddy I got him I
got the timing of a fox or something
like that something equally impressive
to actually have the timing of and not
actually a big animatronic bunny which
is what I am
oh just give me a random bonus but
that's hardly fair okay so I just need I
need to buy how many points I'd okay so
I need either one good game or two more
games look at spring-trap ah it's my
favorite song
oh man the game grump sees the song all
the time here come wait here comes
Barney down to kill you gotta eat your
face off
bin Amana murder your body and eat all
of your limbs and stuff you in my face
and then I'm oh no oh I'm gonna come
again now don't you run away from me and
now II know that I am just your friend
and I love you for ever and ever and
ever ever here I come I go
gosh that was bad ending but I didn't
stick the landing on that song there but
you know made me feel good in my heart I
kinda wanna I'm kind of all
oh that's cool I can get a companion oh
ok so oh man I wonder if I could I'm
gonna try Bonnie first I didn't know
that they gave me special power-ups oh
how do I use it I don't know how to use
it
how are you
I don't know how to easy oh ah no I used
it I dig it dig it dig it okay so it's
only usable in the office but that's
actually handy-dandy because what if I
because there's got to be something to
it that I can make him run out of power
okay so I just got to wait a little bit
he's looking right at me he's looking
right at me I ain't gonna move what you
think I'm a goof
I know goof ain't a goof
all right I might be goof okay okay now
go
I want more points I want more points I
want to run him out about I want to run
out of time and I want to run him out of
power cuz there's a lot to escape
does that loud to this game but it's
interesting this is why I like playing
games like like five nights freddy games
that are interesting it's like an
interesting way to look at it and I
haven't played the original game in a
long time Fifi Oh errand girl
what about oh I can using both mine you
two both baby baby baby baby baby baby
white wok wok wok wok wok wok wok wok
wok wok wok wok 101 oh I believe the
creeping down the hallway and he's gonna
get you and eat all your intestines and
he will
I'm just gonna try to get his power down
because I'm pretty sure I can get his
power all the way down I'm going to eat
your face and then rip out your
intestines and you are going to see your
face and on my face then you're going to
knew that time and good I can't eat off
and thanks and I'm handsome I am really
cool in something Hey oh it's quick ha
ha ha Oh blessed I use the power hmm I'm
gonna get this I'm gonna get him out of
power he's gonna be all out of power I
wonder if it's like multiple cut lovely
couple Ilyn Aidid
I'm gonna get him out of power it's
gonna happen
yeah yeah I'm not gonna get him because
I'm gonna I'm trying to play the power
game here I'm gonna get him out of power
he's gonna be out of power I know he's
gonna be out of power I know I can get
him out of power I don't know I didn't
train him from Bower last time while
this guy is an idiot oh yeah there I am
oh look it's me
oh there you decide to actually be a
goofer what a goof what a goof what a
goof God longs on goofs TV I am going to
eat all up I will eat your vase and your
lungs and eat your nipples then I'll eat
your butt and then your peen peen peen
I will eat your titties and your monkey
and your body and your brother and your
sister hi I'm Bonnie I am good and I
will beat you down into thee something
here we go now he's oh no 5:00 a.m. oh
no he's gonna get gosh got too much
power
well maybe I'll find out what happens
when I run out of time see if it didn't
do the thing where that one time that it
was bad instead of being good I mean
it'd be close I guess if I can get in
there I don't think it's gonna happen
it's gonna hit 6 a.m. then yeah dang I
washed I'm such a goof
what a big goof I am I lost wow I didn't
know they booed that's a bunch of bull
cos screw don't boo me
I thought something cool is gonna happen
ok I'm gonna get him out of power I know
I can take a while
880 dear dear dear dear oh dear look
it's really epic music but I'm gonna get
this I know I can
I'm gonna get him he's at 40% at 3m this
is kind of a weird backwards thing about
everything that I'm like but all my
instincts are screaming that this isn't
exactly how this is supposed to go don't
matter because I have got you baby I've
got you baby you're done this time
you're done so you're done aroni
I'm not gonna attack you but I mean
you're done what I'm saying is that
you're done you're dumb and you're done
you're dumb done does it like scoot the
time forward because the cool down does
jump down I don't know if that's the
case it might do that
I'm going to get you
a
oh this right down to the wire huh
yes yeah yes Oh Oh what now all that
such oh god what would have
saved me the original then such horse
hock okay what happens if I use this
okay so what did that do what is it what
good was that oh my god is that that's a
load of baloney what does that do what
does that do I don't know what that do
it's like I can use it once in here and
then when I get to the office like the
cool down comes back again maybe it's
just a cool effect to be able to do that
but I mean I'd like a little more
practicality and the things that I get
yes I guess wound lacy fuzzy I see foxy
I see Fox he's a little camera there
okay I don't know what he's gonna do
Kovacs you gonna do bad you do oh I
gotta get him like out of here I go in
the office
oh it's doubly usable I can use it once
outside once in the office oh that's
that's very nice that's that's like
incredibly nice that's super duper nice
dahm do dahm dahm do dahm ooby drew
deleting okay don't a little bit it up
either he's gonna run out of power or
Fox is gonna get one or the other at
this point
Evan they're usable again that's nice
except for foxy that might be by design
but I don't know I'm a Barney what are
you gonna do nothing apparently you're a
big idiot look at me look at me look at
me look at my face oh there you go ah
too late
could have looked at me done that then
I'm gonna try I don't know I can kind of
get the power win now
if it'll actually let me win probably
hey buddy
hey hey buddy hey buddy Oh where's all
you all where'd you power go buddy
what oh oh okay
all right then oh good I still learn I
guess cool I think okay that was less
dramatic than I thought it'd be but at
least I can get the chica plush now and
I'll have the entire onslaught brigade
okay let's see what foxy can do
go for it foxy go my bud yes oh oh he
got it
oh no oh no he did it
oh no ha ha BAM okay there we go I did
it I won I won the game okay so I'm
pretty sure that's all there is to this
game I got all the plushies I didn't
kill him via foxy though but it has a
chance to fail
imagine if I was playing on easy mode I
would out there but I did pretty much
everything the game wanted me to do and
I won't go to ez mode again because I am
no puss scratch that
okay so that's pretty much all the game
has for me I mean I didn't kill him via
foxy but I bet I could if I tried it on
easy mode but I think that's all theirs
doesn't seem to be any more secrets
about the game that I could find I did
as much as I could so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
got other like cool fan made games like
this one please let me know I would love
to play them but just the basic
recreations are the ones that I usually
don't like to play so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
so it's good with my jokes get
self-referential how does getting
self-referential when i get slightly
panicked